[Music]
good morning Hank it's Tuesday May 6 ok
Hank so today's video comes in a number
of parts but I can't tell you how many
parts in advance because I have enough
time to like go through and like map it
out and everything because it's just
like so crazy busy here at the
International Reading Association and I
have a very limited amount of time in
which to make this video so I'm just
gonna like do it as I go oh boy when I
get like excited and busy I get almost
hanky and panky ins a nice word it's
like Nietzschean but you know less
frightening ly nihilistic ok
part 1 Hanks belated birthday
nerdfighters you guys should really go
to the video that this one is a response
to and look at the responses to those
videos because a lot of people made Hank
a lot of Awesome presence in video form
thanks to everyone who did that you made
me look like less of a jerk as a brother
and I appreciate it
but even so we shouldn't pass up this
opportunity to do something awesome so
here's what we're gonna do
nerdfighters you have 15 seconds or one
photograph to show yourselves doing
something that Hank would think is
awesome I'm gonna leave it vague like
that so you have some room for
creativity
so nerdfighters you have until Saturday
night at midnight to send your pictures
or videos to sparks fly up at gmail.com
and email address which is repeated and
textual form in the video info part 2 if
you live in Indiana or North Carolina
please vote today remember nerdfighters
you vote count chocula part 4 eventful
wait hold on a second john from 45
minutes ago this is john from right now
and i've got a question for you you
can't count to 3 i mean i know you're
bad at math but let's just go over it
really quickly first comes part 1 then
comes part 2 then comes part 3 god me
from 45 minutes ago is so stupid
so nerdfighters as you know from
yesterday hank maureen johnson and i are
going to be speaking together at this
library in Grand Rapids Michigan on
Thursday at 6:30 p.m.
details in the video info this is
something that we might want to do more
often so we've set up a profile at
eventful calm and if you go to the link
that's in the video info or down here at
the Ning you can request that we come to
your city and then we might come oh hang
by the way my tripod for today's video a
stack of brand-new Paper Towns galleys
so I'm going to give away an advanced
readers copy of Paper Towns to one of
the nerdfighters who sends in a picture
or video to be included in the Hank
would think this is awesome birthday
project okay I really got
this thing but I'll see you tomorrow
like literally actually hooray